and it's nice to see you again I got to
see any room and I got to tell you I was
actually terrified that one time you had
to drive me around and you said I
handled it well you played it so well I
had no idea this means I'm a good liar
good glasses on - that's like Oh three I
heard no I don't even know but I
remember the hair it was definitely my
December era yeah my pleasure yeah I've
seen it I have yeah I have my wife she's
a big fan as well so are my children so
even my oldest daughters been yeah yeah
I hope you didn't pay too much for your
ticket we did I mean it was so good okay
this is a serious question I love
television nights I love that film is it
realistic do not run my dreams go it is
very close of course Hollywood's
embellish some but yeah I mean if we
can't laugh at ourself as a sport then
we shouldn't be out there but I think
they hit on quite a few things that
really do exist in the world of NASCAR
racing I mean yeah we're rolling
billboards out there I'm just the play
on all that throughout the movie is
fantastic yeah I love when I go to a
NASCAR event I mean the people watching
I love those people those are my people
real class everybody is it's like
everyone is so comfortable in their skin
everybody is there for a party it's like
a country fest it's amazing it's awesome
I love it well after seven championships
you decided to retire this season why
you know I'm just looking for some
balance this is my 30th year as a pro
racecar driver which is hard to say
thank you it's been been an amazing run
my
21st season in NASCAR and then this year
when it finishes up with me my 19th year
is a the top level drivers a cup driver
so it's you know I'm ready for some
balance I'm not done working and racing
I still have a lot of things that I want
to accomplish and really compete in some
bucket level you know races and events
and kind of check those boxes but two
young children wonderful wife life all
that stuff that I just want to balance
it out so there's so many things you
love to do but at the same time you
don't want to miss out on anything
especially when your kids are so yeah
sure cuz they want to play with you
right now
they don't once they're to you know I I
had a moment last fall where just
something shifted in my head and it's
never been about statistics for me and
and stained the course would be for me
to chase trying to win an eighth
championship more and more and that's
not what I'm about and what I want to be
about it's more about the journey and
the racing and the funds so once that
shift happened in my mind I've been able
to let go and I'm really excited to see
what 21 brings that's so cool man I'll
tell you what you never know I never
knew I'd have this show so you never
know what your life has in the next year
so but you just had your final race at
your home track right correct well how
did you feel about that kind of
emotional yeah very very not only my
home track but the place of my first win
my family was up in the flag stand
waving the green flag they had me out in
front of the field leading everybody
around for this five wide salute so
highly emotional say wow that's so cool
that's what I love about that crowd too
though everybody is so supportive and
therefore everyone that's why I live
with that NASCAR vibe to every time I've
gone it's just a really big family but
how does your wife handle your dangerous
career because I know my brother-in-law
races around and I'm just like nah I was
like yeah I don't yeah you know
educating her has been key we've been
together 18 years and that was right
after when we first started dating was
right after
it's a shame dill senior's tragic death
happened just after we started dating
and she was able to learn so much about
crash dynamics in the safety that
followed and then what I do to be even
more safe in the car they're really
educating her was part a big part of it
all and then my daughter's now at her
age where they're asking those questions
so I'm needing to educate them to are
your daughter's like you are they
adrenaline junkies they like to dabble
for sure yeah they're like what kind of
things we're in Colorado a lot in the
summer so we're obviously there in the
one or two skiing so skiing hiking
mountain biking motocross riding a bike
yeah there's their go-karts yeah we have
a lot of fun there we are
oh my gosh that's adorable is that your
wife
it is she's on the left oh my gosh yeah
she's like I got this yeah I like it's
like a Texas woman all right well what's
the girliest thing you've done with your
girls because we have a lot of like are
they called girl daddies I think that's
what kind of jokes we've had a lot of
them on this show and I love that I'm
involved in all levels of what goes on
but I'm under a lot of pressure to have
my toenails and fingernails painted a
lot of pressure
yeah honestly I've seen my husband paint
my daughter's toenails our eldest when
we first got together and he does a
really good job like better than me I
found out that I'm not bad at braiding
hair recently he's gonna do yeah I don't
know he had horses growing up so maybe
because he did that with their Mane I
don't know yeah let it yeah oh I can
braid I played sports oh I'm really bad
at the hair I'm good at I'm good at the
pretending so like the tea parties and
like when I'm cast as sometimes I'm you
know I'm stepmother or
I'm good at the pretending stuff yeah
yeah yeah but I'm not good at the
hairpins yeah just one just a little
girl a little girl hello
she'll be three three awesome
congratulations hey April 23rd that's
right a day before mine get out of here
Taurus Taurus kill you let me know what
I'm in for
we're sweet until we're not so do you
ever let people drive you this is always
my thought with people that are racecar
drivers do you not like no chance no
chance I mean for one did you remember
how to drive and she's the most cautious
driver which drives me crazy so no
chance I'll let her drive but yeah
control freak I'll admit it but the
other thing that that you're gonna find
funny is I get motion sickness really
easily so if you don't drive no boats
all happened to me when I was pregnant
so I was just vomiting all the time it
was wonderful um and I literally would
not let anyone drive and they're like
well what if you vomited the wheel I'm
like I got a bag yeah good cause if I'm
in that seat I get so so so bad if
you're in control you're not that's so
true yeah if I'm driving the vehicle I'm
fine now you should put me in a cab or
something in New York it's awful oh yeah
just all those roads they're just like
crazy great drivers bother knocking do
what those taxi drivers in New York are
some of the best drivers I've ever seen
yeah but it doesn't matter how good you
are this every five seconds is like not
what I want a recipe for getting sick
maybe just like creep up on it maybe
don't just try and ride there behind I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this